very differently than joe biden's
weekend
donald trump did a rally in pennsylvania
ostensibly to promote
john fetterman's opponent mehmet oz
and josh shapiro's opponent
doug mastriano ostensibly i say because
every trump rally is actually about
himself and donald trump coming out and
says the current president of the united
states right joe biden
is the enemy of the state he used to say
the media was the enemy of the people
now he says the president is the enemy
of the state as you know this week
joe biden came to
philadelphia pennsylvania to give
the most vicious hateful and divisive
speech
ever delivered by an american president
other than every trump speech i guess
vilifying 75 million citizens plus
another probably 75 to 150
trump thinks there might be 225 million
trumpists in the united states
but he's never been good at counting
that we know be accurate about it
as threats to democracy and as
enemies of the state you're all enemies
of the state
he's an enemy of the state you want to
know the truth
so there it is a former president
calling the current president an enemy
of the state
and the dystopian authoritarianism
didn't stop there
uh trump also went on to say without any
evidence that john fetterman the guy
running against memit oz
is taking all sorts of hard drugs
there's no evidence of that fetterman
supports taxpayer-funded drug dens
and the complete decriminalization
of illegal drugs
including
heroin
cocaine
crystal meth
and ultra lethal fentanyl and by the way
he takes them himself
it's completely out of nowhere
[Music]
there's no evidence i've seen
that
fetterman uh is thinking i mean it's
crazy
and part of this is this new almost
dictatorial authoritarian thing that
trump is doing which is calling for the
death penalty for drug dealers
they kill 500 people during a lifetime
and i think it's much worse than that i
think that's only what we hear about
it would stop
i i if you didn't get it down 75 80 90
from day one i'd be surprised
and these committees that they set up
it's laughable it's a horrible thing we
would solve that problem so fast and i'm
calling on republicans and democrats
immediately to institute to get to
washington and institute the death
penalty
for drug dealers you will no longer have
a problem
and the crowd cheers which is maybe the
scariest part i mean listen we know
trump loves dictators and this
this is straight out of the duterte
playbook this is straight
sort of out of the xi playbook this is
what dictatorial authoritarian autocrats
do and trump now openly saying kill the
drug dealers and by the way when trump
was in power he let numerous drug
dealers out of prison he pardoned a
former drug trafficker he pardoned 13
drug dealers during his last month in
office so it's also total and complete
hypocrisy now
here's the point at which trump's
cognitive state was questioned
trump said that facebook founder mark
zuckerberg
last week visited trump at the white
house and kissed his ass last week you
remember in the campaign i used to say
if these people get in we're going to
end up with venezuela on steroids i said
it many many times i never thought it
was much of a possibility but i never
knew people could cheat like that not
like that
last week
weirdo
is a weirdo mark zuckerberg came to the
white house kissed my ass what the hell
is he talking about
and the audience finds it completely
last week zuckerberg kissed your ass at
the white house
sir i've looked after them
sir i'd love to have dinner i'd love to
bring my lovely wife
all right what a bizarre i mean
something is very wrong something very
serious is going on if trump thinks that
he met with zuckerberg it all honestly
it reminds me of what this is sad
but later in fred trump's life when he
was suffering very seriously cognitively
um
he sort of worked in like a fake office
it was like the truman show remember the
great jim carrey movie where jim carrey
thought he was living a normal life but
it was all stage managed for him um
they would like put papers on fred
trump's desk and they would have a phone
where someone pretending to be i mean
like i guess it was his secretary but it
they weren't really doing any work
he would speak to his secretary on the
phone
it almost is like is that what's going
on with trump does trump think hey
a guy with a fake curly hair wig this is
mark zuckerberg sir he's here to meet
with you oh mr mr president um we want
to go to dinner
is it possible that there's like a
truman show type thing going on with
trump or has trump just have no idea
what's going on it's very very strange
and then in this next clip this is
really interesting
in this clip you can really just feel
the jealousy and envy
dripping off of trump about barack obama
president got anywhere near
i think we got like 10 million more
votes than obama got obama you know
obama so popular
so popular
he's so popular they say he's so
handsome oh obama's so happy
he's such a great speaker what does he
say
he says nothing so basically trump is
very jealous of barack obama because
obama's popular
and more handsome than trump and a
better speaker than trump i mean that's
as childish as this is that's what he's
saying and then this is beyond belief
trump criticizes fetterman
as being spoiled for living off of
family money this is beyond parody if
you know trump's background axes
he is a spoiled and entitled
socialist loser who leeched off his
parents money you know he lives on the
parents body
until taxes
he is a spoiled yeah and of course
donald trump
has basically his entire fortune because
of his father really really wild stuff
i was going to play the clip of the
completely unvarnished transphobia that
is now a regular part of these rallies
it's the exact same three stories trump
always tells you know the weightlifting
stuff
and the swimmer and that teachers
shouldn't be allowed to teach
transgender so i'm just going to skip it
but a real tale of contrasts the biden
speech over the weekend and the trump
speech let's now look at some of the
people that went to the trump rally
imagine this scenario you try logging
into your email account to see that your
password was changed a few hours ago
except you didn't do it and then you get
notifications of activity from your bank
and from your credit cards but you
didn't do any of it that is what
identity theft is like it can happen
very quickly
and if you don't act fast it can get
worse we've dealt with this at the david
pakman show you can find videos about it
and that's why i protect myself now
using aura our sponsor aura is identity
theft protection fraud monitoring
password management and an antivirus all
in one easy to use app aura will monitor
the dark web for your emails passwords
and social security numbers and we'll
send you alerts quickly to your phone
and email aura also gives you near
real-time alerts on suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone was opening a
loan or a credit card in your name and
if you sign up at aura.com pacman you
will get a free two-week trial which you
can use to see if your login credentials
have been leaked online
i would want to know that right away use
the link below